Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Doki Doki Literature Club. Alright.
We're picking up where we left off. Who should I show my poem to well gotta go with Monika. Monika. Hi, Monika. Hey again, Morp!
How's the writing going? Alright, I guess. I'll take that as long as it's not gonna be bad
I'm happy that you're applying yourself. Maybe soon you'll come up with a masterpiece. I wouldn't count on that
I am pretty skilled but Morp no poet. You never know. Want to share what you wrote today? Sure, here you go
Give my poem to Monika. All right. I like it, Morp! Really?
It's a lot cuter than I expected. Ha ha oh jeez. No no no it kind of makes me think of something
Natsuki would write, and she's a good writer too, so take that as a compliment
Mm, alright. Okay, if you say so...
Yep
By any chance, have you read by anything by Shel Silverstein?
Yeah, where the sidewalk ends?
Maybe a long time ago. He's famous for telling all kinds of stories in just a few simple words
His poems can be funny, endearing, or even sad. And sometimes. They're only a few lines long
They might even make you feel like they've written their be written for kids, but if you think about them
They can express views of the world that would apply to anybody I see so you're saying that Natsuki is kind of like that
Sorta, maybe she's not an expert, but you probably won't find much filler in her poems they might be easy to write
But they're super challenging to get the meaning through so I can see why it would be your kind of poem to explore
But anyway you want to read my poem right? I like the way this one turned out, so I hope you do too
All right, let's take a look
sue
Save me the colors. They won't stop bright beautiful colors
flashing expanding piercing red green blue an endless cacophony of meaning noise
The noise it won't stop violent grading waveform squeaking screeching piercing sine cosine tangent
Like playing a chalkboard on a turntable like playing a vinyl on a pizza crust an endless poem of meaningless
Load me
Load load me
Load beat load me load load you low
Wait, load?
What huh it's even more abstract than your last one huh ha ha ha ha I guess it's just the way I write, huh
I'm sorry if you don't like it. No. I never said that it's this kind of thing
I've never really seen before I guess I kind of like playing with my space on paper
Choosing where and how you to space your words can totally change the mood of a poem it's almost like magic
The way I wrote the lines really short makes it feel like they're trying to speak over the noise
I see it's still hard for me to tell what it's about though
sometimes asking what a poem is about isn't the right question a poem can be as abstract as a physical expression of a feeling or
A conversation with the reader so putting it in that way not every poem is about something anyway
Here's Monica's writing tip of the day sometimes. You'll find yourself facing a difficult decision
When that happens don't forget to save your game
You never know what you might change your mind when something unexpected may happen it is this tip even about writing
Ok what am I even talking about? Ha ha that's my advice for the day? Thanks for listening?
All right
Okay, all right well I visited the URI last zoo URI first you want my cutie poem there it is
Let's see what you've written for the day, mmm. That's pretty good more were you influenced by seeing everyone's writing sales yesterday
I guess you could say that I was also a bit surprised by how differently everyone writes
So I respect you for trying new things you don't need to be afraid to be a little more daring
Metaphors can go a long way
Don't feel like you need to work your brain like turning a bunch of gears try letting your mind wander
Through your feelings and write down the things you see in here
That's one way to truly enable your reader to see into your mind. It's a very intimate exercise I
See okay, that's certainly interesting technique. Thanks for sharing. I have um well an
Example of that if you'd like to read it of course, I would that's what I like
I like that was it the poem you wrote for today
URI nods and timidly hands me your poem ah
velder Hakuna
It happened in the dead of night while I was slicing bread for a guilty snack
My attention was caught by the scattering of a raccoon outside my window that was I believe the first time
I noticed my strange tendencies as a an ordinary human. I gave the raccoon a piece of bread my subconscious
well aware of the consequences
Well aware that a raccoon that is fed will always come back for more
The enticing beauty of my cutting knife was the symptom the bread my hungry
curiosity the raccoon an urge
the moon
Increments its phase and reflects that much more light of my cutting knife
the very same light that glistens in the eyes my raccoon friend I
sliced the bread fresh and soft the raccoon becomes
excited well perhaps
I'm merely projecting my emotions onto the newly satisfied animal
The raccoon has taken to following me you could say that we've gotten quite used to each other
The raccoon becomes hungry more and more frequently so my Brett is always handy every time
I brandish my cutting knife the raccoon shows me its excitement a rush of blood
classic
Pavlovian conditioning I slice the bread and I feed myself
again
All right
it's more of a
Novel than a poem it's a story
Was a little more daring with this one than yesterday's I can see that
You can see that. It's a lot more metaphorical not really
I don't know if it's my fault, but I can't imagine what this poem is about that's right
It's a bit closer to my preferred writing style using the poem as a canvas to express vivid imagery and conveying emotions through them
Yeah, if you I take it at face value, then I can't even figure out what it's supposed to mean well
I think it's something that different people can relate to in their own way
I wanted to express the way it feels for me to indulge in my more
Unusual hobbies it's those sort of things that I'm usually forced to keep to myself
You know feeding raccoons and such so I sometimes enjoy writing about them
Why do you keep them to yourself?
be- beCAUSse
They're embarrASsing and people would make fUn of me. Don't you have anything like that Morp?
Well, yeah?
I guess I do.
I feel like everyone is a little something like that the best we can do is respect each other in our individuality
Even if it's difficult sometimes and some things make us uncomfortable
After all if I haven't learned to embrace my own weirdness I would probably hate a myself
I might be ranting a little bit now, but I'm glad you're still a good listener. Oh
You're welcome who should I show my bum do I don't even know what the hell just happened there all right
How about say are you sorry sir and Cherie? Oh?
I like this one more it has some nice feeling in it and
Does it mean it's better than yesterday's I?
think
Whatever, I like I'm both yeah, that's not very helpful. You know well. I'm not very good at figuring out
If poems are good or bad
But that's just why I go by mama Hart if it makes me feel things then it must be a good poem
I'm not sure that's exactly how it works then again more guests. Conveying feelings is a pretty important part of this whole thing
Yeah, maybe honestly morp. Don't even know what kind of writing you like in the first place. Yeah me neither
oh
Why don't you at least try to give it some thought? Oh you want to write something for me? That's so sweet Yeah, right?
But you're always thinking about other people you need to think about yourself once in a while
If you don't you might end up getting hurt at some point
That's weird I don't really know what you mean by that, but I'll try to keep it in mind well whatever anyway
Let's see hmm. I
Guess I like happy poems right sometimes
They're like sad poems do something a little bit of both happy and sad there's a word for that right
Melancholy I think is the word you're looking for
Enter sweet, that's also a word melancholy might not be the right word. Yeah, I like things that are happy and things that are sad
Happy and sad. I can't see you liking something that said C or E. Well
I like happy the most but sometimes when you have a little rain cloud in your head a sad poem can give a rain cloud
The little hug and make a nice happy rainbow you are disgustingly happy yeah
Say re that's unexpectedly poetic. No. It is maybe I'm getting better in my feelings after all thanks more
I should get to write that down then you can read my bum now okay, all right here. We go all right bottles
I pop off my scalp like the lid of a cookie jar
It's the secret place where I keep all my dreams little balls of sunshine all rubbing together like I'll bundle kittens
I reach inside with my thumb and forefinger and pluck one out boink
It's warm and tingly, but there's no time to waste
I put it in a bottle to keep it safe
And I put the bottle on the shelf with all the other bottles
Happy thoughts happy thoughts
Happy thoughts in a bottle all in a row my collection makes me lots of friends each bottle a star like to make amends
Sometimes my friends feel a certain way down comes a bottle to save the day night after night more dreams friend
And more bottles deeper and deeper more fingers go like exploring a dark cave discovering the secret hiding in the nooks and crannies
digging and digging
Scraping and scraping I blow dust off my bottle caps it doesn't feel like time elapsed my empty shelf could use some more my friends
Look through my locked front door finally all done
I open up and in come my friends
And they come in such a hurry do they want my bottles that much I frankly pull them from the Shelf one after another
Holding them out to each and every friend each and every bottle
But every time I let one go it shatters against the tile between my feet
Happy thoughts happy thoughts. Happy thoughts in shards all over the floor
There was supposed to be for my friends my friends who aren't smiling they're all shouting pleading something
But all I hear is echo echo echo echo echo
Inside my head
Wow okay Wow
Holy crap. Holy crap. Yeah. Holy crap indeed. Holy crap sorry
Did you really write this of course I did didn't I tell you yesterday?
I was gonna write the best poem ever yeah, but I mean I didn't expect something like this coming from you Monica
Taught me a whole lot and I've been really in touch with my feelings recently
I see that it's almost kind of creepy creepy well not exactly maybe because I'm so used to be you being so cheerful
I'll never mind think of to heart about this huh something goes wrong here the point is it came out good
So you should be proud of it well, thanks
I feel like feel like I was meant to express myself. This way it even helps me understand my own feelings a little bit better
Writing is like magic. You've gotten pretty passionate about this huh, I hope you keep it up
Yeah, writing is the best I'm gonna keep writing until I die ah don't get ahead of yourself
Sarah's always had a habit of giving obsessed with something before dropping it no more than a week later
Yeah wonder if this is one of those times, but seeing the passion and her eyes makes it hard for me to be pessimistic
Okay, all right Natsuki Natsuki time here we go
Mizuki hey, how's it going? She keeps glancing at me been back at the poem by now
She must have read it more than once. Are you supposed to be bad at this is that a compliment? No. I mean you know
Natsuki struggles to find the word she wants, I just expected a lot less after why'd you show me yesterday?
That's all well. I guess I just got lucky with this one. Huh yeah exactly
You just got lucky. You know don't get used to it. You won't always manage to write poems is cute
I mean, I mean well written no
Oh, that's that's how it is my poems cute. No. Why are you smiling? It's all I can look you things
That's if he shoves my poem back towards me huh reading again?
I decided is now so great after all it's too cute and okey-dokey. It would only impress
You know girls who like that sort of thing?
For some reason that suki is incredibly easy to see through well anyway, you're gonna read mine now right judging by your taste
You'll probably like it a lot. You'll probably learn something too. Don't forget who the real pro is
Maybe like spiders. You know what I heard about Amy Amy likes spiders
Icky wiggly hairy ugly spiders, that's why I'm not friends with her amy has a cute singing voice
I heard her singing my favorite love song every time she sang the chorus my heart would pound to the rhythm of the words
But she likes spiders. That's why I'm not friends with her one time
I hurt my leg really badly
Amy helped me up and took me to the nurse I tried not to let her touch me
She likes spiders so her hands are probably gross. That's why I'm not friends with her amy has a lot of friends
I always see her talking to people she probably talks about spiders. Whenever friends start to like spiders, too
That's why I'm not friends with her. It doesn't matter if she has other hobbies. It doesn't matter if she keeps it private
It doesn't matter if it doesn't hurt anyone it's gross
She's gross the bet of the world is better off without spider lovers, and I'm gonna tell everyone
Is this a poem about
judging someone for one thing
No matter, how good they are if you let one thing ruin that about them?
It's it's a bad way to judge someone. This is a really good poem
Is this a really good one? I like this I really like that
Judging someone by one characteristic flaw that you don't like about them personally no matter how good it is
huh. Ah!
That's a really good poem and speaks well. That's great. I leave that one not bad. That's really good quite a bit longer
Yes, it is was way too short. I was just warming up
Hope you didn't think that was the best I could do no of course not
Anyway, the message is pretty straight for him it is Boehm. I doubt I have to explain it sometimes
You can explain complicated issues with much simpler animal analogies
And it helps people realize how stupid they're being like anyone who would agree with the subject of this poem is an ignorant jerk
Do you know what people are like that do you know people like that of course? It's about everyone how everyone thinks might
That doesn't matter it can be about anything
I wrote it to be easy to relate to everyone has some kind of weird hobby
Or a guilty pleasure something that you're afraid if people find out they make fun of you or think less of you
But that just makes people stupid
Who cares what someone else likes as long as they're not hurting anyone into makes them happy
I think people really need to learn to respect others for liking weird things huh, that's funny Yuri wrote about something similar today
Uh-huh did you say Yuri? Yeah? She said her poem was about an unusual hobby of hers
I didn't really get it
But she says something similar to you that people shouldn't make each other feel insecure about this things really well
I mean Yuri's pretty weird, so I wouldn't doubt that she has some weird hobbies not that there's anything wrong with that
It's not like the judge or anything no suit he has trouble finding words
I guess I should try not to be so mean to or
She feels insecure about a weird babies and stuff
I mean I always hate people who make me feel insecure and Yuri made me feel insecure yesterday
But the way you put it it sounds like she's learned her lesson
Oh, I would say so even if a writing style is really different. I'm sure she'll appreciate the message in your poem
That's what I do best after all I don't like writing unless it's a good message to take away from it like conveying emotions is
Important, but I want to make people think don't just feel remember that I'm gonna write a good one for tomorrow, too
So look forward to it
Get back your cards don't make me bring out the billy club. Where's Mack he represented your cute heads bash
It right in go back me threatening
I'm something extra plant something extra planned today
So if everyone could come sit in the front of the room
Is this about the festival well sort of oh do we really have to do something for the festival?
It's not like we can put together anything good in just a few days well
Just end up embarrassing ourselves instead of getting any new members. That's a concern of mine as well
I don't really do well with last-minute preparations. Don't worry about so much. We're gonna keep it simple, okay?
We won't need much more than a few decorations see Ori has been working on posters
And I've designed some pamphlets he can give out during the event okay. That's great
No, but that doesn't tell us what we're actually gonna be doing for the event. Oh, sorry. I thought you heard about it already
We're gonna be performing
Morning, but uh Monica
Yeah
We're gonna be having a poetry performance each of us are gonna choose a poem to recite during the event but the cool part is
we're also gonna let anyone else come up and recite poems to
Series putting it out on all the posters in case anybody wants to prepare of ahead of time
Sarah who's been coloring a poster holds it up for us to see are you kidding me Monica?
You didn't you didn't know Reese are putting those posters up. Did you yeah well?
I did do you really think it's that bad of an idea? Well no it's not bad
But I didn't sign up for this you know
There's no way I'm gonna be performing in front of a group of people like that I agree with Natsuki
I could never in my life do something like that imagining it URI shakes her head in fear guys no Sayuri
I understand where they're coming from remember that netsuke and URI never shared their poem with anyone until it just a couple days ago
It's a lot to ask for them to recite their poems out loud to a whole room through people I guess I kind of overlooked
that so, I'm sorry, but
I still think we should give it our best
We're the only ones responsible for the fate of this club if we start the event and each put on a good performance
Then it will inspire others to do the same and the more people who perform the better
We'll be able to show everyone that literature is all about yeah, it's all about expressing your feelings being in a bit with yourself
Finding new horizons and having fun. That's right, and it's those reasons that we're all in this Club today. Don't worry
Don't you want to share that with others?
To inspire them to find the same feelings that brought you here in the first place
I know you do I know we all do
And if it does that's all it takes standing for a room for two minutes about reciting a poem that I know you can do
it
Okay now Sookie and URI remain silent Sayuri looks worried I guess that leaves me with no choice I agree
I don't think it's too much to ask
I think that say Ori and Monika have been really trying to get hard to get new members
The least we can do is help them out a little bit. Well. Maybe but
It looks like Natsuki doesn't have any arguments left oh
Okay, fine. All right. I guess I'll just have to get over it. It's all right whew thanks netsuke. What about you URI
Huh Gary dejectedly glances around at everyone else's expected faces
sigh
I guess I don't really have a choice. Oh, that's everyone. You're the best Yuri
This club is seriously gonna be the death of me. Oh gosh wait
Foreshadowing, I port Chatham you'll be fine Yuri, but anyway
Let's move on to the main event I want you to choose a poem of yours
We're gonna be practicing reciting them in front of each other
Monica
Well if you can't recite your poem in for the club. How do you expect to do it in front of strangers? Oh?
No, don't worry. I'll start off to help everyone feel a little more comfortable. Can I go next of course now?
let's see Monica flips through her notebook to a specific poem she has in mind for herself gonna say before this okay that
Stands behind the podium the title of this poem is the way they fly
ahem
Monica begins reciting her poem her clear confident voice fills the room more than that her inflection is pristine
She knows exactly how to apply emotion behind each line
She recites bringing the words to life
Is this something she's done before or is she simply a natural a glance around me everyone has their eyes on Monica say or he?
Looks amazed URI has an intense expression on her face that I don't understand finally Monica finishes a recitation the four of us applaud
Monica takes a breath and smiles that was Oh
Monica ah thank you very much. I was just hoping to set a good example. Are you ready to go next Sayori?
Oh, I'll go next I will Oh
Yuri's fired up all of a sudden your clutches a sheet of paper between your hands stands up keeping her head down
She walks quickly over to the podium this poem is called Yuri anxiously glances at each of us you can do it Yuri
It's called after image of a crimson. Yuri's voice shakes as he starts reading the poem just a moment ago
She practically refused to do this
Why is she so suddenly putting in so much effort as?
Yuri gets past the first couple lines her voice changes it gets deeper the room dark the lights all go out
Everyone feels a cold breeze rush in through the window right
Her quivering words transform into the sharp syllables of a fierce and confident woman
The poem is full of twists and turns
And it's structure that she enunciates with perfect timing this must be a rare glimpse into the whirling fire Yuri keeps concealed inside her head
Suddenly she's finished
Everyone is stunned Yuri snaps back into reality oops there goes gravity mom's spaghetti starts spilling out of
her pockets and glances around her. I
It's up to me to save the situation I'm the first to start applauding
All right there we go it's not that we didn't want to applaud for her
But we're caught off guard that she- we must have forgotten as we applaud Yuri holds the poem to her chest and rushes
Back into her seat
Yuri, that was really good don't you dare upstage me ever again. I will kill you. Thank you for sharing
Looks like Yuri is down for the count, okay?
I guess I'm next then Sayori hops out of her chair and cheerfully walks to the podium. This one's called my meadow
ah, ah ha ha sorry I giggled
Sayori. It's a lot harder than I thought how did you guys do it so easily? Ah.
Try not to think of it like you're reciting to other people
Imagine you're reciting it to yourself like in front of a mirror or in your own head
It's your poem after all, so it'll come out best that way I see I see
Okay, then
Sayori begins her poem
Somehow, it feels like your soft voice was made as a perfect match. The poem isn't  aimlessly cheery like Sayori is
It's serene and bittersweet, if I were to read this on paper
I probably wouldn't think too much of it, but hearing it come from Sayori's voice almost gives it a whole new meaning
Maybe this is what Sayori meant when she said she likes my poems. It's like I get to reach more deeply into someone
I thought I knew through and through Sayori finishes it and we applaud I did it good job Sayori. Huh even Morp liked it
I guess that's a good sign if Morp like. What does that even mean? It came out nicely Sayori.
The atmosphere of the poem fits you really nicely
But it might be that other poems wouldn't work quite as well with that kind of delivery
Eh, I don't really understand. In other words
I've seen poems of yours where that sort of gentle delivery wouldn't work as well
They might need a little more force behind them depending on what you're reading. Oh, I know what you mean
That's, well I've been practicing that kind of thing. It's just embarrassing to do in front of everyone. Hehe
Then next time I'm gonna make you pick a poem that challenges you a little more
We don't have much time before the festival you know. Okay!  Now who's next Natsuki
Hmph, don't make me go before Morp,  it's not like I can compare to you guys anyway might as well
Let Morp lower everyone's standards a little before I have to do it
Natsuki oh come on now. It's fine, it's fine.
I might as well get it over with but it's not like I have much of a selection of what to read
I'll go with what I wrote for today
I stand up and step in front of the pro podium everyone has their eyes on me making me feel awkward. Oh, hello
Well, thank you for all standing in order of tallest to shortest and also biggest boobs to smallest boob
I appreciate that, that's really welcome. I guess okay. Anyway. I recite my poem since I'm not exactly confident in my own writing
It's hard to put energy into it despite that once I finish I receive applause anyway
I'll applaud myself. Don't worry Morp has Morp's back.
Sorry I'm not really as good as everyone else. Don't worry about so much
I think it's less about your abilities more about your lack of confidence in your writing. That's something that will improve over time though
Yeah, maybe all right, then that just leaves you Natsuki. Yeah
Yeah, okay. I'm going Natsuki begrudgingly gets out of her seat and makes her way to the podium the poem is called
It's called
Why are you all looking at me because you're presenting. Hmph.
Anyway, the poems called Jump.
Natsuki takes a breath once she starts reciting the poem her sour attitude disappears a little while she's still a little
Unenthused her poem has a rhythm and rhyme to it
It's not Natsuki's trademark style
And it worked surprisingly well when spoken aloud the words feel like they bounce up and down as if giving life to the poem
Natsuki finishes and everyone applauds. She huffs back to her seat
That wasn't so bad, was it? Easy for you to say you better not make me do that again
Oh, well, do you at least feel prepared enough to recite a poem in front of other people?
I mean doing it in front of other people will be way easier. I can put on whatever face
I want for other people, but when it's just my friends. It's just embarrassing
That's a surprise Natsuki. I think it would be the other way around for me well
That's just how it is, so well I guess in that case you won't have much to worry about it for the festival
That's it
I want to thank you everyone for coming through it might be hard
but I
hope that you all have an idea of what it's like now. Make sure you pick up all them and get enough practice
Before the festival okay?
I'll be making pamphlets so let me know at the time what you'll be reciting
Geez you should probably find some other way poem to recite instead. That's fine, too. It doesn't have to be your own
I'm already pleasantly surprised that you're all putting in the effort for the club
It makes me really happy and you know what that means I guess uh yeah, no problem
Okay, everyone. I think that's about it for today
I know the festival is coming up, but let's try to write poems for tomorrow as well
Okay, it's been working out really nicely so far so I'd like to continue with that. As for the festival,
We'll finish planning tomorrow, and then we'll have the weekend to prepare. Monday is the big day!
I can't wait. I can do this, I can do this.
All right
Great, I stand up. There's no way I'll be able to find the same enthusiasm as Sayori and Monica
But I'll do my best to get through it. If it's for the sake of the club, and  impressing Monica
But I'll have to do my best. Ready to go Sayori?
Yep, yeperoonie. Look at you two, always going home together like that. It's kind of adorable isn't it oh?
geez guys don't make it such a big deal out of it must be a little nice, so well ah
How am I supposed to respond to that it's okay Morp, you don't have to say it whatever. Let's go already
All right, I walk home with Sayori once more gotta save one more time even though
It's only been a few days a lot of things have already changed, but today Sayori
Is being a little quieter than usual on the way home. Hey Sayori. Eh? Sorry
I was spacing out. No wonder. I was thinking about something from earlier
I liked how we get to- I mean- Sayori fumbles with the words
So let's just say that one day Natsuki asked to walk home with you. Huh? What would you do?
What kind of question is that you're kind of putting me on the spot here?
Decision decision, huh
Well, I mean, it's
If she has to walk home is it out of my way? I mean we're conveniently living near each other so
But you know
You know
I probably still yeah, I probably still would walk back with you, I guess
Yeah?
Yeah sure okay. Sayori, you really think I would ditch you for Natsuki? Yeah
But but she's so cute and fun to be around
Geez I already see her in the club every day besides you always seem to really like going home together
I wouldn't just ruin that for you. You're so silly Morp, Morp you so silly. You think about me too much sometimes
You're so silly now Natsuki would deserve it if she wanted it so
Sayori I've already made up my mind once and forever this decision here is final this takes president over everything
I mean honestly. I don't like being
I don't like being narrowed down into the people I can walk home with but you know it is. If Yuri, now if Yuri
That's a different story Monica- If Monica Uh drop you like a hat. I really can't figure you out sometimes. Sorry besides
What's the point of speculating something that's never gonna happen, huh?
the conversation trails off. Kind of a weird thing for Sayori to care so much about
But I wanted to respect her and keep her happy, too
Then again the festival is only a few days away who knows what will happen in that time. Death, Death will happen
probably
probably oh
God I have to write another one. I have no idea how this one's gonna go oh boy all right hang on
Um
Oh
Okay, that's probably horrible everyone hates me now, okay, so I'm gonna try to write, I've written one for Yuri
accidentally, and I've written one for
Natsuki, I'm gonna try to write one for
For Sayori
Hope ah..
There we go
Y ou go boom boom bum bum bum bum shame
Cool, cool cool. Aladoo. Gah there's a poof, can't skip poof, poof, poof, poof. Okay there we go, poof
poof poof, buh duh buh duh buh buh, buh. Jumpy uh nope that's not what I want. Okay here we go
Where's the family?
There we are we got the family and doop boop boo boo doo doo boo the?
loop-de-loop
The email ah shit okay, not doing good joy. Yeah, there's some joy. It's oh
Alone! Doop boop, baba doo ba doop. Fun!
Baba doo calm! Doo la doop
Fear bump beep bop boop boop boop hair uh whoops then dude that tears there we go
How about du Loup boot up party up bee la doop, but but hurt up, but bit tdoki-doki shit
Baby do but play a little up but boxer library
There but uh nature love it up a new boat together love a double-dip boat nest me, I shit. That's my Babbitt
Childhood hey, I think I got it you can think I got a predominantly good one. Oh
man
What what is it? I'm the last one here again. Don't worry. I just walked into were you practicing piano again
Yeah, ha ha ha you must have a lot of determination
No one's anything sorry this club
I'd miss it well and maybe not determination
But I guess passion remember that the club wouldn't be here if it wasn't all for you
And I'm super happy that you're all willing to help out for the festival - I can't wait for the festival
Oh, it's gonna. Be great. All right weren't you complaining about it. Just yesterday Natsuki well
Yeah, I'm not talking about our part in the festival, but it's a whole day of school
Where we get to play and even all kinds of delicious food you sound a bit like say
Orry all of a sudden Monica
Did they usually have fried squid?
Squid that's a pretty specific thing to look forward to oh come on. Are you saying you don't like squid?
No miss squid lover huh? I
Am handling squid lover 99. We all know that I didn't say I don't like it besides
What do you mean by you of all people because?
Writing your name Monica
Yeah
that's how you say my name at all also that joke makes no sense in translation I
Never mind, let's just focus on your own event for now okay
fine fine fine
Your reactions aren't as fun as URIs or say or YZ anyway excuse me. Where is C or E anyway? Oh there you are
Say Orion that is at the desk in the corner the room looking down at nothing. Why walk over to her
Hey, say Ari. I waved my hand in front of her face. Yeah, you're spacing out again. Ah
Sorry, don't mind me you can go talk to everyone else huh is everything all right of course
Why wouldn't it be it feels like you're a bit off
Sorry for assuming things tease you worry too much about me. I'm fine see
Shows me a big smile
Don't let me distract you from having fun with everyone. Okay, all right
If you say so I weirdly glance at say Ari before turning back towards everyone else
But the conversation is already dispersed and everyone back at their usual activities
Maybe I should ask Monica if she's noticing anything about C or E. Recently since they've been preparing for the festival
They must be spending a lot of time together. I timidly approached Monica who's shuffling from papers throughout her desk more
What's up? Hey? This might sound a little strange, but uh have you know same things up with C or E recently?
Anything up with her and what weight do you mean?
Maybe I'm reading into it a little too much, but she seems a bit downcast today
Oh you think so can't say I've noticed anything about her Monica peers across around the C or E
Who's idly dragging a rubber eraser up and down her desk? Maybe there is something on her mind, but I'm surprised
I'm not the one asking you
Morp you certainly know her a lot better than I do yeah, but she's never really like this
She's always talked to me about things that bothered her, but this time when I asked her she was really dismissive
Sorry, I know it's not your problem
I just wanted to ask if you knew anything, so I'll drop it now no no no no it's important to me, too
I mean I'm also friends with her, and I also care about the well-being of my club members you know
Maybe I'll try talking to her myself with my robot emotions that always works out for everybody
Why not yeah, you sure about that she seemed like she wanted to be left alone
Are you sure maybe she just has a hard time bringing out up with the person of interest oh?
Person of interest what do you mean by that I'm saying that maybe the thing on her mind is you more me
you come to that conclusion why the handsome guy like me with amazing social skills and
Lifelong childhood friend oh, I probably shouldn't say too much, but Sarah talks about you more than anything else you know yeah
She's been so much happier ever since you joined the club it's like an extra light was turned on inside of her
Always like that. She's always been full of sunshine. It's not any different now than it always has been yeah
You're so funny more
have you thought that maybe you've always seen her so cheerful because that's just how she is when she's around you I
Said too much. I'm sorry. What do I know anyway? I didn't mean to jump to conclusions
you should prolly just forget about what I said, I'll tried to talk to her so try not to think about it for now ah
all right Monica smiles
Meaningfully, I know she said to forget about it
But I already know that I won't be able to get her words out of my handy
Monica stands up from her desk and walks across the room to where she or he is sitting. I watch her kneel down next to
Sarah and generally talk to her, but she's keeping her voice so quiet that I can't hear from here
I sigh and sit myself down. Oh the burdens of having all the ladies after you
Oh wow a curse it is to be as handsome as me
I know Sarah Tommy enough to worry about her been to have fun with everyone else
That's impossible to do when she's behaving like this exactly how much I do care I care for her
Do I do I care that I'm letting this weigh me down so much now
I'm feeling like I'm the one behaving out of the ordinary, but there's nothing I can do besides wait for Monica
Hey, oh, sorry excuse me, sorry well, I look up to see Natsuki next to me
Are you just gonna sit there and stare nothing?
There's no much time so I'm sorry. I didn't mean to make you worry or anything, so I've been worried about you
I was just now Sookie glances down at her side
She's holding a volume of manga in her hand that's right something just came up for a minute
But we can get started now
I won't make you wait any longer jeez now you're making me feel like a jerk
Something's bothering you then you just tell me to leave you alone
And I will I mean assuming that you didn't feel like talking about or anything. She practically mumbles the last part
No, I'm probably making it seem like a bigger deal than it is I've just been thinking about say Orie. That's all so
you're
Thinking about whoa?
Yeah, she seems pretty down today
But she didn't want to admit it to me so I can't help but wonder if something's Avenue her oh
Well first of all you should really work on your phrasing, but anyway, you're her best friend, right?
Yeah, I guess so yeah, then in that case
I think you should trust her a little more if she needed you then you'd be the first person she would go to right
Well, I guess that's true. I mean some people just have those days
You can't always avoid it if anything she probably just doesn't want you to worry about her because it's not important
Yeah, that kind of was what she said to me. Maybe it's not right for me to go against her wishes
Exactly so shut up and read this manga with me
She needs you worry about her. Then it'll be a lot more obvious
Yeah, I should have thought of it that way from the start Natsuki fiddles with the book. She's holding her hand she
She really means a lot to You doesn't she ah oh what no nothing no like garbage they threw out on any day
Don't get the wrong idea or anything. We've just been friends for a long time. It's normal to be worried about your friend
I mean you were worried about me, so I
Was not and we're not friends so screw you and go to hell
Geez if you're fine well. Let's hurry and get started already. Yeah. Yeah, all right whoo
Wait what's goin on? Oh?
Okay everyone after some time passes Monica calls out from the club room
Why don't we share our palms now before I know what everything's back to normal okay before we move on
I'm gonna end this one here and
It is interesting I feel like it's about to take a turn at any moment here III don't know why I expected just like blood
to shoot out of the windows right away in this game
But I have a feeling it's getting to that point where the truth is being revealed
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you think down the comments below and write your poems down there as well and as always I will see you
in the next video
Buh Bye!!!